[Music]
many marketers today are struggling to
bring together data silos across
multiple systems platforms and point sas
solutions for a holistic overview and
understanding of their marketing program
others find that reporting and
measurement processes are tedious
limited by analyst resources or
inaccurate due to outdated or disparate
data sources i'm piccola and today i'm
going to share how google cloud helps
marketers drive better marketing roi and
enhances customers experiences by
breaking down data silos increasing time
to insight and bringing industry-leading
ai to marketing analytics the digital
landscape is changing marketing teams
are looking to prepare for a
privacy-forward future with google and
other partners google cloud supports the
end-to-end customer journey with
marketing analytics a unique solution
built with native connectors google ads
and google marketing platform offering
faster time to value for marketing
organizations
welcome to marketing analytics series
where we teach practitioners about
google cloud marketing analytics
solutions and showcase their use case
and business value in this video we'll
discuss three ways you can use google
cloud to help transform marketing
analytics in your organization
the first way your organization can
leverage google cloud is through
audience segmentation
you can leverage google cloud machine
learning to build differentiated
audiences to be used in your analysis
and in your marketing campaigns
audience data often lives in multiple
places from crm systems to web analytics
like google analytics 360 or adobe
analytics but how do you as a marketer
leverage this valuable data
many organizations have a tremendous
amount of data that could be meaningful
for audiences or other marketing
activation but are unsure about where it
lives and how to best harness it and
many times they don't even know this
data exists
google cloud allows you to import
audience data into your data cloud
marketers can use bigquery to bring all
this data together
if you're familiar with bigquery it is a
serverless and highly scalable and
cost-effective multi-cloud data
warehouse designed for business agility
bigquery also has machine learning and
ai built right into it and you are able
to build and train several ml models to
start segmenting your audiences into
meaningful marketing targets
the ability to create audience
segmentation allows marketers to glean
deeper insights on their audience and
the best part is that you are able to
activate these audiences back into your
ads channel through google marketing
platform a few examples of the type of
audience segments you can build in
bigquery include high customer lifetime
value segments propensity to buy for new
customer segments propensity to churn
for customer retention
the next way your organization can
leverage google cloud is through
marketing insights google cloud allows
you to bring data together from siloed
systems to gain comprehensive marketing
insights you can use to improve roi and
streamline channel performance reporting
google cloud customers use bigquery data
studio and looker our modern business
intelligence solution to create a
one-stop console for all of their
marketing performance data
from ad impressions to on-site traffic
and customer data with native connectors
google marketing platform for easy
activation
uncover marketing insights that can
easily be shared with stakeholders
across your organization to democratize
marketing performance and insights and
get everyone looking at a single source
of truth
google cloud can also help enable
attribution modeling beyond your current
ads platform or dsp
this is an ideal solution for clients
who find that the data-driven
attribution solutions built into
analytics 360 displaying video 360 are
sub-optimal for their specific use case
or data limitations
finally google cloud taps into the power
of google trends data allowing marketers
to better understand consumer insights
and find areas of the product innovation
early on
now the final way google cloud's
marketing analytics solution allows
marketers to deliver enhanced customer
experiences to their users is through
consumer sentiment analysis like
creative analysis and recommendations
this starts with bigquery where you can
aggregate online comments and then
analyze the sentiment with our natural
language api so you can better
understand how your brand and marketing
messages are resonating with your
customers
bigquery with built-in ml also allows
for scaled creative analysis generating
insights from successful creatives to
understand their impact on ads
performance last and certainly not least
marketers can build with unified app
analytics with bigquery and liquor
centralizing common data sources for app
centric organization to unlock consumer
and app insights across marketing
channels to build better app experiences
and that is just the starting point of
what is possible with google cloud for
marketing organizations google cloud
also supports many advanced use cases
like customer data platform dynamic
pricing and much more
we'll dive deeper into each of these
solution areas in this monthly series
and show you how it actually works
in the meantime please check out our
website
read more about our marketing analytics
solutions on google cloud if you're
eager to try out these solutions you can
sign up for the bigquery sandbox which
lets you explore public datasets like
google trends and run queries without a
credit card check it out at
cloud.google.com
bigquery docs sandbox
if you enjoyed this video please make
sure to like the video and click the
subscribe button to watch more videos
like this
[Music]
you